vous trouvons notre envoyé spécial à
kharkiv cyril payen bonjour cyril quelle
est la situation alors où vous vous
trouvez
eh bien je pense que vous pouvez voir
grâce à bord d'un de moura qui cadre et
bien nous sommes dans la seconde ville
ukrainienne seconde ville du pays 1,5
million d'habitants en temps normal
c'est un un jour normal ici et puis nous
sommes sur la principale avenue il n'y a
personne ou presque personne ou alors
est bien des camions militaires quoi
c'est un canon de 125 qui passe alors
évidemment les combats vous le disiez
très justement on sait c'est ici c'est
associons kharkiv set interrompu il ya
environ une dizaine de jours avec le
début de ces fameuses contre-offensive
l'ukrainienne qui sont certainement un
des tournants de cette bataille dans
laquelle on est entré dans le quatrième
mois pour autant pour autant ici c'est
absolument impressionnant il y à la loi
martiale toujours extrêmement strictes
les quartiers centraux sont totalement
vidées de leur population
nous sommes arrivés dans la nuit dans
une ville complètement morte on estime
que 60 % de 7 de la population de cette
ville de l'est ukrainien est parti a fui
et surtout eh bien on redoute il ya eu
des sirènes d'alerté à la bombe auquel
ses yeux créé les ukrainiens sont
maintenant tellement habitués qui ont
retenti toute la nuit et on sait qu'à la
part la partie orientale la partie est
de la ville et bien les forces russes
sont toujours stationnés et menaces et
c'est bien là l'angoissé ici
existentielle je peux vous le dire pour
les rares habitants que nous avons pu
croiser depuis hier soir l' angoisse
d'une d'un nouvel d'un nouvel assaut
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
entendu beaucoup de tanks depuis la
levée du couvre-feu à l'aube ce matin
converger vers le centre de la ville se
rendant vers l'est de kharkiv donc oui
un calme précaire avec des contre
offensives village par village qui sont
opérés par là-même crânienne et qui
tente de reprendre des zones occupées
qui l'ont été par les russes pendant de
longues semaines dans cette région de
l'est de l'ukraine a à 30 km de la
frontière russe là où se trouve
justement bonjour cyril récemment vous
aviez enquêter avec mohamed farhat sur
des exactions russes commises en dans la
région de kiev qu'en est-il dans dans la
région de kharkiv vous trouvez qui est
proche de la frontière avec la russie
eh bien là c'est le scénario de
l'horreur il est vrai que dans l'est les
villes qui sont les villes résidentiel
autour de kiev qui ont acté la
résistance on s'en souvient au mois de
mars qui ont empêché en fait le siège de
kiev dont butch aoste au mail ir pin des
villes qui sont malheureusement par
rapport au taux de destruction et aux
horreurs que l'on redécouvre et surtout
au nombre de victimes collatérales c'est
à dire les victimes civiles des conflits
vont sans doute entré dans l'histoire
les images ont fait le tour du monde
mais ce qu'il se passe et c'est
certainement là aussi un grand symbole
de l'occupation russe eh bien c'est ce
qu'on leur rende découvrir dans ces
régions qui sont encore une fois
frontalière de la russie où dès le 24
février il y a plus de trois mois les
forces russes ont pénétré massivement
pour tenter de prendre la seconde ville
ukrainienne et bien il y a eu une
occupation extrêmement longue dans
toutes les régions qui vont vers le
dombass au sud de là où se trouve où les
combats font rage et évidemment
l'histoire retiendra certainement la
tragédie l'horreur et j'ose le dire la
barbarie d'actes que l'on peut avoir
auprès des témoignages que l'on commence
à recevoir dans ces régions qui ont été
occupées pendant de très longues
semaines par les forces russes viols en
série
tueries en masse et puis également la
disparition de jeunes mineurs c'est une
affaire qui provoque beaucoup qui
préoccupe beaucoup la procureure
ukrainienne qui doit juger pour crimes
de guerre voire génocide l'armée russe
pour cette période d'occupation
puisqu'il y avait énormément de mineurs
qui ont disparu dont on dit ici qu'ils
ont été emportées par la mer l'armée
russe comme je cite et trophées de
guerre donc cros est certainement le
début de cette litanie d'horreurs que
l'on découvre ici après cette occupation
mais n'oublions pas le dombass et la
clim et son os aux occupations
actuellement en guerre actuellement une
énorme pression militaire donc on n'ose
imaginer tout ce qui peut se passer au
moment où l'on parle dans ses autres
occupé par les unités militaires russes
cyril payen depuis kharkiv pour france24
merci beaucoup cyril